before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round up truth or dare
all right we have malik
hi
all right truth or dare
truth or dare
what is the most random thing we might
find in either of your closets
um
do you i bought a pair of boots once it
was like after a happy hour where it was
like oh yeah these are cute and then
like the next one i was like those
aren't cute those aren't cute but you
kept them i kept them because maybe
they'll be cute one day they're almost
like a they're like a doc martin but
like a platform what am i what am i
doing like i'm going to a room
no no i have this really bizarre it's my
favorite store in new york city if
you're ever
in town please go to abracadabra they
have vintage stuff
it's like a dream everything you could
ever imagine and i got this crazy
headdress with like horns and feathers
and like pearls that
go and i just keep it in there because
every once in a while it's just time to
put that thing on yes and just walk
around the house and it's it you see it
in the closet and you're like oh okay
that's an outlier
and yet i love sporting it whenever i
can
about you anything rando in your closet
i have a leather black and white cowboy
jacket with uh tassels all up and down
the back and it's yeah oh my god hey
i'll trade you a pair of boots for that
jacket i want that or maybe you need to
put your boots and the jacket together
with your headdress we gotta look one
malik i would love to see you in that
jacket and thank you everybody for
choosing to spend your time here with us
we make this show for you
so
take it with you
[Music]